The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So.
Last day we started looking at
phase diagrams, and we looked
at unary phase diagrams, one
component systems, and one
component system P versus T,
pressure versus temperature.
And this is the situation
for water.
Water is an exception, because
it's got this negative solid
equals liquid coexistence curve,
but otherwise, you have
large, single-phase regions
here, which I've designated
circle p equals 1, and then
along these lines, we have
equilibria.
So this is liquid goes to vapor,
this is solid goes to
liquid, this is solid
goes to vapor.
And we know that for water, if
we take the 1 atmosphere, if
this is pressure in atmospheres,
the 1 atmosphere
isobar, then that would put
this point at 100 degrees
Celsius, and this point
at 0 Celsius.
And then we have the triple
point, which is solid equals
liquid equals vapor at 0.01
degrees C, and p equals, I
think it was 4.58 millimeters
of mercury.
So that's the triple point.
And we looked at a variety of
other one-component phase
diagrams, and I think we
came to a pretty good
understanding.
And then up here, we have the
supercritical fluids.
So I've got a break
in the line here.
And for water, you reach
supercriticality at 374
degrees Celsius, and up here
at 218 atmospheres.
So these are not phenomenal,
these are not geological
pressures at all.
And so that's if we want to
the decaffeinating of
coffee and so on.
And so what happens here, is you
have a highly compressed
vapor or a highly rarefied
liquid, and you end up with
solubilizing power of a
liquid, but transport
properties of a gas.
So this stuff has really
good diffusivity.
So it can penetrate into
interstices and do its work
very quickly, to say nothing of
the fact that you're up at
374 degrees Celsius or higher.
So today what I want to do,
is I want to look at
two-component systems. So
component number is circle c,
c equals 2.
So that means now I have
to deal with pressure,
temperature, and lowercase
c is composition.
I want to know how things
vary with composition.
So let me give you an example.
Suppose I have two substances,
A and B.
So here's substance A, and I've
got its one-component
phase diagram.
And in this case, I'm going to
put solid-liquid vapor in the
conventional setting, where
the solid-liquid line is--
the coexistence curve has
a positive slope.
So this is A, and let's say I've
got B over here, and it's
got its solid-liquid coexistence
curve, and so
we've got its melting
point, and whatever.
So now the question I want
to ask is, what happens
if I mix A and B?
And let's just say, here's the
melting point of A, so this is
at p equals 1 atmosphere.
And here's the melting
point of B.
And I want to ask the question,
how does the melting
point of the mixture vary?
So let's say I'm going to
connect these, and I want to
ask, what happens if I've
got an AB mixture?
So I'm going to put lowercase
c here, which is
concentration.
So at the one end, I've got 100%
A, and over here, I've
got 100% B, and I know
those melting points.
Question is, what happens
when I mix them?
Does the melting point-- is
it just a straight line?
Is it a linear variation?
Do you go through
a local maximum?
a local minimum?
Or do you go wild?
I mean, what happens?
So a question you might ask
is, suppose I made a 50-50
alloy of 50% A and 50% B.
If I knew the end-member
melting points, could I
predict this?
Or if not, do I have
an archive?
Remember the phase diagram
compendium is an archive.
What is the value
of the melting
point at 50-50 or 75-25?
So that's the question
I want to ask.
Now this is getting really
messy, because now I have to
plot pressure, and I have to
plot temperature, and I have
to plot composition.
So this is really
crazy, right?
I've got pressure, and I'm
going to have composition
here, and I'm going to have
to have now a third
axis, aren't I?
I'm going to have to
have a third axis.
I'm going to need a
temperature axis.
And I've got to make a
three-dimensional drawing.
And this is messy.
But we're in luck, because 3091
is solid state chemistry.
So as solid state chemists,
we're more interested in what
happens in the solid here.
Now, I've drawn these lines
with a slope, but they're
really not to scale.
It turns out that, you know, you
can move 10,000 feet up or
down in the atmosphere and have
a huge variation in the
boiling point because this
line is shallow.
But this line is virtually
straight up and down.
You have to go to geological
pressures to change the
melting point very much.
And so, as a result, this
is almost insensitive to
pressure, to first
order, right?
So we can say solid equals
liquid is almost insensitive
to pressure, whereas liquid
equals vapor is very sensitive
very sensitive to pressure.
But we don't care about
this so much.
So what I'm going to do
is throw it away.
I'm going to throw it away, and
just say, let's look at
just T versus C.
Temperature versus composition
on the strength of the fact
that the melting point and all
of these things are mildly
dependent on pressure.
All right.
So now I'm going to give you
three different types.
There's many, many different
types of binary phase diagram.
So now we're going to be
looking at C equals 2.
So instead of a unary, this is
going to be called binary.
Binary phase diagrams. And they
come in all shapes and
sizes, but they can
pretty much be
classified in several bins.
And I've made the
classification.
So classify binary
phase diagrams
according to their bonding.
It all comes back electronic
structure and bonding.
Vary by bonding.
Because bonding, then,
ultimately indicates
solubility, and that's what
we're looking at here.
We're going to look at how well
A dissolves into B, and
how well B dissolves into A.
That dictates solubility.
So it all comes full circle.
So I've made this up.
You're now going to find
this in the book.
So I just decided, for ease of
teaching 3091, is I'm going to
just give the different types.
And so I call them type one,
type two, and type three.
You're not going to find
that in the books.
I made that up, because
it's simple.
So type one.
What's type one binary phase
diagram, according to me?
What is the type one?
It means complete solubility.
So A and B are completely
soluble in one another as
solid and liquids.
That's the first thing
that you'll see on a
type one phase diagram.
And the second one is, a change
of state is present.
And you know the only change of
state we care about here is
solid goes to liquid.
So we're going to show solid
goes to liquid, and the thing
is totally, as they say in
California, totally soluble as
liquids and solids.
Now, here's some bonding rules
that you can think about.
So what would be the
characteristics of two
substances A and B that would
give complete solid
solubility?
Well, one thing is they'd have
to have identical crystal
structures.
That would heighten the
chances of this.
Identical crystal structures.
So if they're both FCC metals,
you've got a better chance of
making an infinite variation in
solution composition than
if one is an FCC metal and the
other is a BCC metal because
FCC will just sit on
the lattice site.
But there's more fine
structures.
Second one is similar
atomic volumes.
So if we're going to have a
substitutional solid solution,
let's make sure we're replacing
oranges with
oranges, and not trying to put
a grapefruit on a site that
normally is occupied by a lemon,
because there's going
to be a size restriction
there.
And the third thing is, even if
they have identical crystal
structures and similar atomic
volumes, you can still run
into trouble with respect to
complete solid solubility if
you have a large variation
in electronegativity.
And I'll show you an
example of that.
So if you have a small
difference in
electronegativity, it means
there's a low propensity for
polarity, and ultimately no
chance of electron transfer.
So I think it's pretty cool.
So I wrote those down, but was
disappointed to learn that for
metals, they were enunciated
about 75 years ago by the
British metallurgist
Hume-Rothery.
So I can't take credit
for this.
This is one name.
It's one of these hyphenated
British names.
He's Sir da-da-da-da
Hume-Rothery.
So he has the Hume-Rothery
Rule.
And he called such systems that
mix as binaries forming
isomorphous, meaning they
have the same structure.
So let's take a look at the
prototypical isomorphous phase
diagram, and it looks
like this.
We're plotting temperature
versus composition.
We threw away the pressure
coordinate.
So I got pure A on the left,
pure B on the right.
Little c is concentration,
so it varies from
100% A to 100% B.
And the vertical axis
is temperature.
So one extreme, I've got
the melting point--
this is a melting
point of pure A.
And at the other extreme,
I've got the melting
point of pure B.
So that, we know.
And now the question is, how
does melting point vary as a
function of composition?
And for an isomorphous phase
diagram, it looks like this:
lens-shaped.
Up here is all liquid.
You see A and B mix in
all proportions.
And down here is all solid.
And furthermore, it's an
all-liquid solution.
It's a mixture.
And this is an all-solid
solution.
And then comes the piece
that if you take enough
thermodynamics, you'll be
able to rationalize.
I'm simply going to tell you
without proof that when you
have a multicomponent system,
when c is greater than 1-- so
we're in that situation.
Now, c is 2.
When c is greater than 1, it is
impossible to move from one
field, up here, this is--
I'd better put the label
on it-- this is a
single-phase field.
So up here, p equals 1, because
it's homogeneous
liquid solution, p equals 1.
When you're in pure materials,
you can go
from solid to liquid.
But when you're in a
two-component system, you
cannot move from one
single-phase field to a second
single-phase field
without moving
through a two-phase field.
And we'll get to that, what it
means to move from one field
of p equals 1 to another field
of p equals 1 requires
traverse or transit across
a field of p equals 2.
And so what's in here has
to be the end member.
So this must be liquid
plus solid.
So I'm going to call it slush.
They have a slush in here.
The other terminology that
people give this is, it's
lens-shaped, right?
Looks like a lens.
So let's call this lens shape.
So we're going to use
the Latin word for
lens, which is lens.
But we want to make
it adjectival.
So we're going to use
the adjective--
what's the genetive
form of lens?
Lentis?
So we will call this
lenticular.
This is lenticular.
The phase diagram has
a lenticular shape.
Looks like a lens.
And you know, just as over here,
I showed you, every line
represents a coexistence
curve, right?
The lines are all coexistence
curves.
These lines are coexistence
The line up here is liquid
equals vapor, so this one must
be the coexistence of the two
things on either side.
So what do I have here?
I have liquid.
Here I have slush.
So I'm going to write that.
So I'm going to write the
equilibrium, liquid goes to
liquid plus solid.
And this line, this coexistence
curve, it's called
the liquidus line.
This is the liquidus
equilibrium, the liquidus
coexistence curve, and so on.
And so what's the liquidus?
The liquidus is the lowest
temperature.
So you pick a composition.
The liquidus is the lowest
temperature at which you can
have a single-phase liquid
solution, OK?
So liquidus equilibrium.
And the liquidus is the lowest
temperature at which all
liquid is stable.
You go below that temperature at
that composition, you start
making solid, because slush
requires that there be some
solid present.
And then the lower line, it also
is a coexistence curve.
So on the one side,
I've got solid.
On the other side,
I've got slush.
So I'm going to write
that one down.
That solid goes to liquid
plus solid.
And that's called the solidus
equilibrium, or that's the
solidus line, the solidus
coexistence curve, and the
solidus is the complement.
The solidus is the highest
temperature at which you can
have all solid present.
So you pick a composition, and
I'll tell you what the highest
temperature is at which
you'll have a
single-phase solid solution.
So solidus is the highest
temperature at which
all solid is stable.
All right.
Good.
And I'm going to look at
a few of these things.
It's always fun to see if
I'm on track with the
Hume-Rothery rule.
So here's copper nickel.
They're both FCC metals.
So we've got copper melting at
about 1085, nickel melting at
about 1455.
And there's the phase diagram,
lenticular phase diagram.
So up here is all liquid,
and then--
this is all metallurgy
terminology.
A solid solution of A and
B, they call alpha.
Metallurgist looks at that, goes
oh, it must be a solid
solution, OK?
So there's p equals
2 in between,
p equals 1, p equals--
Here's a ceramic system.
This is nickel oxide,
magnesium oxide.
It's not metals, but they have
identical crystal structures,
very similar atomic volumes.
They're ions, so we have
nickel and magnesium
substituting for one another
on the cationic sublattice.
So they must have very
nearly equal sizes.
If I look at this, and I see a
lenticular diagram, it means
they must have similar atomic
volumes, which means the
dominant defect in here must
be Schottky, not Frankel
because Frankel needs a big
difference in atomic volume.
If you have a big difference in
atomic volume, we wouldn't
have a lenticular
phase diagram.
So here's-- mag oxide melts at
2800 degrees centigrade.
It's a great refractory.
You can hold molten
iron in it.
And here's nickel
oxide down here.
All right.
Here's an interesting one.
This is gold nickel.
Both FCC metals.
Shade your eyes from
the lower part.
Just look at the upper part.
It looks lenticular.
It's what you'd expect,
gold and nickel.
They're both, you know,
card-bearing metals.
But you've seen already, with
the cesium-gold, gold has a
fairly high electronegativity.
And what happens is that you
get over here, at about 33
atomic percent of nickel in
gold, you have an atomic ratio
that allows to have something
that starting to approximate
electron transfer.
So it's almost as though you
have a lenticular phase
diagram between pure nickel and
this nickel-gold compound.
But up in here, it's nice
lenticular stuff.
All right.
What's the next one?
Oh, yeah.
So now I want to go in and I
want to start talking about
what goes on inside here.
So what I'm going to do, is
I'm going to blow this up.
And I'm going to start at 40%,
40 weight percent nickel, and
I'm going to say, what happens
if we take a crucible that's
40 weight percent nickel and
copper, and we cool it from
all liquid at 1300, down to all
solid at 1200, pausing in
that slush zone at 1250?
So we're going to take snapshots
and say, what's the
contents of the crucible look
like at 1300, at 1250, and at
1200, and come out of it, have
an appreciation for what all
of this stuff means.
So let's start our experiment.
So we're going to have
three crucibles here.
And we're going to start with
40% nickel in copper, and
that's going to be the
experiment we'll perform.
So I've got three crucibles.
And so if I look at the phase
diagram, here I am.
This was 1300 degrees C, this
was at 1250 degrees C, and
then this was at
1200 degrees C.
So at 1300, that's trivial.
1300 for this thing, it should
be just all liquid.
And maybe it's copper.
I know at this temperature,
it's going to be blinding
white heat.
So it doesn't matter.
I could use this.
But I felt compelled, it's one
of those rare opportunities to
use colored chalk.
So I want this to sort
of be copper-colored.
The meniscus is going to look
like this, because the liquid
metals have a very high
surface tension.
They want to ball up.
So you're going to have a
meniscus looking like this,
and this is all single
phase, all liquid.
And over here, I'm going
to do the easy one.
If we get down to 1200, it's
all solid state, right?
At 1200, I'm going to end up
with something that's solid,
and it's going to be
polycrystalline, and these are
all going to be grains
of alpha.
All solid.
And I'm going to label all of
these as alpha solid solution.
They all have the same
composition, which is 40%
nickel in copper.
And these are all 40% nickel.
Now, according to this phase
diagram, when we get down into
the center there, something
else happens.
We end up in a two-phase
regime.
And that two-phase regime is
a regime in which certain
compositions are forbidden
because that's an equilibrium.
It doesn't allow us to have
what's in between.
I think the next slide
actually shows this.
So what I've designated
as c2 is this 40%.
So c2 is now going to park at
that point in the middle.
Whoops!
Want to get into that.
So here's where we are.
We're in the center of that
two-phase regime.
So this is the solidus.
This is the liquidus.
And we're at 1250.
t equals--
And we're at this value.
We started at c2,
which is 40%.
But in this regime,
40% is forbidden.
If you stop at 40% at 1250,
this says that the stable
phases are a liquid
and a solid.
But the liquid has less nickel
in it, and the solid has more
nickel in it.
It's like if this is
a solubility limit.
In other words, if you started
at pure copper, and you
started adding nickel, you can
keep adding nickel until you
get to this concentration.
You try to add any more nickel,
it's like adding too
much sugar to water.
What do you have?
The stuff just falls to
the bottom of the
cup, doesn't dissolve.
That's this.
It's the solid.
Only instead of being pure
nickel, it's still a copper
nickel solution, but
kind of rich.
So I'm going to call
this c star.
It's the solubility limit
on the liquid side.
And this one here I'm going to
call c star on the solid side.
In other words, I could start
from this side, and keep
adding copper to nickel, and I
make a homogeneous alloy until
I get to this composition.
If I try to add any more
copper, I jump across.
So we're here in the middle.
But now, isn't there something
strange here?
It's saying I'm going to have
a liquid that's nickel-poor
and a solid that's
nickel-rich.
And I'm just putting up here
what the diagram says.
And we know that FCC metals,
which is denser, the
liquid or the solid?
The solid.
So down here I'm going to have
alpha, OK, a bunch of grains
of alpha solid solution, and up
here, I'm going to have a
liquid solution.
And the composition here is
c star liquid, and the
composition here is
c star solid.
It's different composition
from this.
Here the composition is equal
to c2, or the 40% nickel.
So I've got disproportionation.
But the total mass, I can't
have sources or sinks.
So I have to conserve mass.
So I'm going to ask you to
just do the algebra.
You've got two equations
and two unknowns.
I know what the n-member
concentrations are.
They're given by the
n's of this thing
called the tie line.
The tie line ties the two ends
of the two-phase region
together, and then we just
do a mass balance.
Well, fortunately, the
metallurgists have thought
about this for a while, so we
don't have to go through and
figure out, well, if two
apples cost 15 cents--
we don't have to do that
kind of thing.
We can just invoke the lever
rule, and it will tell us how
much of the liquid that's
nickel-depleted and solid
that's nickel-rich
add up to this.
And so let's look at
the lever rule.
Basically what's going to happen
here is that the stuff
that started off as 40% nickel,
60% copper, that's my
initial mix, it's going to
break into two layers.
It's going to break into a
liquid layer, which, if you go
to the phase diagram, looks like
it's about 38% nickel and
68% copper, and that's
what we're going
to call c star liquid.
And then over here it's 45%
percent nickel and 55% copper.
And that's what we call
c star of the solid.
And so it's just a lever.
So there's c star.
This is the c2 that we want.
And we want to ask, what's the
relative amount of the liquid
phase and the solid phase?
And why they call it a lever
rule is, look, if you cooled
something that was at
this composition, it
would be 100% liquid.
And if you cooled something at
this composition, it will be
100% solid.
And so it's going
to be a constant
variation across here.
So you use, you take this, and
you know, and I want this
amount, I'm taking this versus
this, kind of thing.
It's a lever construction.
So we'll just put it down.
So the percent of the liquid
in the crucible at 1250--
and then this is a
general thing.
Whenever p equals 2, you'll
use a lever rule.
Percent of the liquid is
given by this one.
The composition of the solid
at the end of the tie line
minus the composition
that you started at.
This is your bulk initial
concentration, divided by the
length of that tie line.
c star solid minus
c star liquid.
And then multiplied by 100%.
So you get a percent, and the
number here is going to be 45
minus 40 over 45 minus 32,
and that works out--
going to multiply by 100, or
else there will be complaints.
And then this turns
out to be 38%.
So what that means is that
if you take this
amount of liquid here--
pardon me-- based on
conservation of mass, if you
drop and hold at 1250, 38% of
that volume is now sitting
here in the liquid, which means
62% of it by volume has
turned into solid.
And the composition here is
different from the composition
here, but if you add up all the
nickel in the crucible and
sum it versus all the copper in
the crucible, you still end
up with 40% net nickel.
So this very powerful.
Because what you can do here
is you can separate metal.
Because I started here with 40%
nickel, 60% copper, and
now I've got something--
the liquid face, I wrote
here, the liquid
phase is now 68% copper.
So can you see that if I'm
clever about this, I could use
this as a technique
for enriching.
And if I'm thinking about
recycling metals, maybe I need
to know something about phase
diagrams because it's a very
simple way of concentrating
impurities or concentrating
the desirable stuff.
Let's look at one other thing
here that's really very
interesting.
Suppose I had something, instead
of c2 at 40%, suppose
I choose a c1.
So this is 40% nickel.
Now what if I take something
that's 35% nickel, and I cool
it down to 1250?
What happens?
If I park here at 1250 degrees,
according to the
phase diagram, that substance
has to phase separate, and I'm
going to end up with
the same thing.
I'm going to end up with
liquid and solid.
Now, isn't there a contradiction
there?
How is it that whether I started
with 40% or 35%, I end
up with the same end members?
What's the missing piece?
The relative amounts
will be different!
The relative amounts.
Here, look.
As I'm getting closer to the
liquid, can you see that
axiomatically, I'm going to
make more liquid and less
solid if I ended up with
something over here?
But at 1250, those are
the end members.
That's the only stuff that's
going to be present.
Ah!
That's so good.
I think I've got some
other stuff here.
Oh yeah.
Oh, this was-- yeah.
So p equals 2.
Lever rule.
Whenever you see p equals 2, you
have two things you think
of. p equals 2 means
phase separation.
And that phase separation means
you're going to get
different amounts, and
the lever rule.
And why I have this Manchurian
Candidate--
it's this movie.
I know there's a remake.
The remake is horrible.
The original, if you see the
original, is about some
fellows that were brainwashed.
They were American prisoners
of war brainwashed in North
Korea and they're brainwashed
to become assassins on cue.
And the cue is the Queen
of Diamonds.
When someone shows the Queen of
Diamonds, they just go into
automatic pilot, and they're
supposed to assassinate the
political figure.
So for you, your Queen of
Diamonds is p equals 2.
When you see p equals 2, you
go, phase separation.
Lever rule.
All right?
No guns, just this.
I just want the formula.
You go, phase separation,
lever rule.
Whenever p equals two.
So what happens in here?
Phase separation.
Boom, boom.
Right there.
Oh, I'm not supposed
to say boom, boom.
Phase separation.
Ta-da!
You know, something.
PC, whatever.
OK.
So let's keep going.
Now I want to look at a second
type of phase diagram.
So the first type of phase
diagram was complete
solubility.
Now the second type of phase
diagram has partial
solubility.
So let's look at that one.
So i call this type two.
And you don't predict
this stuff.
We would give you the phase
diagram and simply ask you,
you know, you're the specialist.
Tell me happens if
I cool this to such and
such a temperature?
You can tell me you get phase
separation, and the
composition of the two end
members, and so on.
So the characteristics, the
bonding characteristics here,
are partial or limited
solubility of A and B.
We're doing all of this for a
binary system A and B, and no
change of state.
So that means either always
solid, or always liquid.
That's not to say that the A
and B never become solid.
I'm just saying that a type two
diagram is limited to a
single state.
So let's take a look
at the diagram.
The diagram looks like this.
We're going to plot
temperature versus
composition.
So pure B on the right,
pure A on the left.
Concentration is the abscissa,
and then the ordinate, of
course, is temperature.
And so the shape of the
diagram is this.
There's the coexistence curve.
It's called a synclinal
coexistence curve.
So above, we have all solid.
And in here, we have
two solids.
So using the metallurgical
terms, this
is alpha plus beta.
Two phase regime, OK?
So let's get those labels up
right off the bat, so we know
who's where.
So outside the coexistence
curve, p equals 1.
Inside the coexistence
curve, p equals 2.
And wherever I'm saying all
solid, alpha plus beta, I
could write all liquid, and then
it goes to l1 plus l2.
So maybe we should do that, to
show that we're multilingual.
So it's either all solid, or
it could be all liquid.
And then this would be liquid
1 plus liquid 2.
And so why do we call
it synclinal?
What's this?
This is an incline.
If I put two inclines
and I synchronize
them, I get a syncline.
And if I don't synchronize
them--
these are two ladders.
I could prop them up.
That's called a syncline.
And if I put two ladders like
this, if I'm really stupid and
I fail physics, if I do
this, they fall down.
So this is called an
anticline, OK?
That's an anticline.
This is a syncline.
It's not a U-shape, or a hump,
or something like that.
This is 3091.
This is a syncline.
Synclinal coexistence curve.
All right.
So what's on here?
What's this equilibrium, then?
Well, the equilibrium must
be this equals this.
So that would be, in the case
of the solid, it's the solid
solution goes to alpha plus
beta, or it could be the
liquid goes to liquid
1 plus liquid 2.
That's the equilibrium.
You can think about it almost
as a solubility.
So let's start over
here on the left.
Let's pick a temperature.
Let's call this T1.
So I can put B into A, and I
continue to get an all-solid
solution, up to this
concentration here.
What happens at this
concentration?
I've hit a solubility limit.
And if I try to put any more B
into A, I get a tie line--
lever rule.
In here is lever rule
time, isn't it?
Lever rule. p equals 2, OK?
So it's solubility limits.
Solubility limits.
All right.
So let's look at
some examples.
Oh, here's this one, actually.
That's why I had a--
you know, if you go to lower
temperature, gold, nickel--
look!
They actually phase separate.
That's shocking.
I always find this one shocking,
because you think
gold, nickel, nice FCC
metals, they should
substitute for one another.
Look what happens.
If you start putting nickel into
pure gold at 700 degrees,
you get the 10 weight percent,
you put any more in, boom.
Right across here.
So this is going to
be two phase.
So if you look at the
solid, what's that
going to look like?
If I'm at, say, 30%, now I look
underneath and I've got a
polygrain system, and I'm going
to have an alpha and a
beta, and an alpha and a beta.
I'm going to have two
different grains.
And now, what's the relative
amount of alpha and the
relative amount of beta?
It's given by the lever rule.
OK.
Let's look at a few
other examples.
Here's hexane nitrobenzene.
And so they've even put
l-alpha, l-beta.
They put the--
actually, that's probably a--
it's hard to read.
But I think it's really an F,
but it didn't come through
very well, so it's the beta
fraction, the alpha fraction.
So you can see how you
use the lever rule.
So up here it's all p.
That's the not pressure,
that's my circle p.
Single phase, two phase.
Drop down to 290 degrees, it
separates into two liquids.
With the hexane--
with two liquids, you'll
actually have them floating on
top of one another, right?
Well, maybe.
Depending if the density
difference is tiny, you might
get a dispersion.
I'll show you that
in a second.
All right.
So p equals 2, lever rule.
OK?
Hexane nitrobenzene.
Look at this one.
This is surprising to me.
Potassium chloride,
sodium chloride.
It's almost lenticular with a
little bit of depression, but
down here, it actually
separates.
This is polymer.
It's a polystyrene,
polybutadiene,
depending on what the--
at low index, polymerization
index, they mix.
At high polymerization index,
the two are mixing.
You get two phase,
single phase.
Changes the mechanical
properties, too, doesn't it?
Now this one--
some systems actually have
a lower critical point.
Oh, I meant to tell you.
You see, there's this
temperature here.
Above this temperature, they
mix in all proportions.
You can ever have phase
separation.
This is the maximum temperature
at which you have
no phase separation.
So this is called the consolute
temperature.
And it's usually an
upper consolute.
The higher you go
in temperature--
it's like saying, do you
dissolve more sugar in cold
water or warm water?
You dissolve more sugar
in warm water.
And eventually, you get to a
temperature high enough that
you can mix in all proportions,
right?
That's the consolute.
Some systems, for entropic
reasons-- and again, if you
take 560 or some of the other
thermal classes, you'll
understand this, but for
entropic reasons, you actually
have homogeneous solutions at
low temperature, and at
elevated temperature, you
get phase separation.
That's funny, isn't it.
So this is water triethylamine,
and they mix in
all proportions at
this zone here.
And then above a certain-- it's
called lower consolute
temperature.
It actually phase separates.
Doesn't matter.
All you care about is
p equals 2, phase
separation, lever rule.
The rest is details.
This is a real hoot.
This is water nicotine.
It has a lower consolute
temperature and an upper
consolute temperature.
So it's got a solubility
bubble.
You see?
Out here, things are soluble.
In here, they're insoluble.
So they are emissible.
So we call this zone, this
region here under the dome, so
to speak, this it's called the
miscibility gap, because
things in there are not soluble
in one another.
But with nicotine, you have a
lower consolute and an upper
consolute, so you have a
miscibility gap that's a
complete ring.
That's cool!
I like this.
All right.
So now I'm going to do
a little experiment.
We have a few minutes, so I'm
going to show you ouzo water.
I'm going to mix it, and I'm
going to actually mix ouzo and
water, and go into the two phase
regime, and then out.
So this is what it
is, all right?
It's oily stuff, you know.
If you're of Greek ancestry, you
know what this stuff is.
All right?
But it's got licorice, it's got
a fair bit of oil in it.
So what I'm going to do, is I'm
going to come in here, and
I'm going to start adding
ouzo to water.
And they're both clear,
colorless liquids.
OK, Dave. Let's go to the--
All right.
So what we're going to do--
this is distilled water.
So I'm going to put some
distilled water in here.
A little bit of distilled
water.
And this is ouzo.
It's clear and colorless.
OK.
Can we show you this?
Let's do this.
OK.
Ouzo, it comes from Greece.
All right.
So it's also clear
and colorless.
That was the point.
Not to show you the label.
See?
It's clear and colorless.
So this is clear and colorless,
and the water, as
you know, is clear
and colorless.
So now what I'm going to do--
see, I don't have
to wear a smock,
or goggles, or anything.
This is great.
So what I'm going to do,
is I'm going to add
some of this stuff.
Clear and colorless.
OK.
It's turned milky.
Why has it turned milky?
Because we've now crossed into
here, and the second phase is
coming out.
But the density difference and
surface tension differences
are so slight, that instead of
having the second phase float
on the first phase, we
have a dispersion, G.
If you go to the dairy case,
and you look at something
called milk, you'll have
the same thing.
Why is milk milky?
Because the fatty phase is a
fine dispersion, and the
particle sizes is dadadada,
versus the wavelength of
visible light, et cetera.
Now if my phase diagram is
correct, and I'm in here, if I
keep adding ouzo, I should
eventually emerge on this
side, and instead of having a
milky dispersion, I eventually
should come here, and now
I'll have a homogeneous,
single-phase solution.
But now it's going to be
ouzo-rich, instead of
water-rich.
You never thought phase diagrams
were interesting.
You don't know.
There we go.
Je vous presente.
There it is.
So what we've done is, we've
come across the thing.
Yeah, that's good.
Just put that there.
Now, David, please, back
to the slides.
May I have the next
slide, please?
That's a joke.
When you have these terrible
speakers at conferences, they
get up there, really nervous,
and they stand up there, and
the first thing they say
is, may I have the
first slide, please?
That's sort of a gag
among scientists.
What's your opening statement?
May I have the first
slide, please?
May I have the next
OK.
So we've done this.
All right.
Now--
yeah, OK, this is just more.
All right.
So now I'm going to
show you absinthe.
Absinthe is the same thing.
Absinthe also comes from
the same family.
And there's a little
culture here.
It contains wormwood.
The wormwood was up at around
200, 250 parts per million.
And what wormwood
does, it's got a
hormone they call thujone.
And thujone antagonizes the
gamma aminobutyric acid, which
moderates firing of the
neural synapses.
Basically, we've got this GABA
that regulates how-- our
brains could work much
faster than they do,
but the GABA regulates.
If GABA doesn't work, you can
start moving so fast that you
get muscle thing, and you get
epileptic, is one example.
But anyways, what it does, is
if you drink this stuff,
instead of being a stupid
drunk, you become a very
high-functioning, very
alert drunk.
And I'm going to show you what
the consequence is in art.
Anyways, the cultural piece
here was that there was a
destruction of the French wine
industry in the 1800s due to a
blight called Phylloxera.
It's like a beetle, and
it ate the vines.
And in fact, the French wine
industry was saved by the
American wine industry.
Vines from New York state were
brought over, grafts were
made, and virtually all French
wine today is on American
stock with the exception,
occasionally you'll see
something says vieille vin.
Old vines.
There was some areas
that were spared.
So what's that have to
do with anything?
It has to do with the fact that
when the Phylloxera hit,
the price of wine went very
high, and the people at the
bottom of the socioeconomic
ladder couldn't afford wine.
So they turn to absinthe.
Absinthe was easily produced.
Thirty years later, when the
vines come back, the French
wine industry wants to
recapture the market.
So there's a Faustian bargain
between the French wine
industry and the Women's
Temperance Union to try to
disparage absinthe.
And there were a few major
show trials that involved
vicious murders in which it was
alleged that the killer
was deranged on absinthe.
And with this, they slandered
the name of absinthe so badly
that it was eventually
banned and literally
taken off the market.
I mean--
you know, we had the Rosalind
Franklin commentary a few
lectures ago.
I hope I never read about you
doing something like this in
order to help your
start-up company
take over market share.
That's not the way you're
supposed to do it.
Anyway, so what--
now, how did they drink it?
They drank it by mixing--
so it's now back, but it's
got very low levels
of thujone, so it's--
David, may we go to this?
So we're going to make a
mix called the louche.
It's a--
OK, here it is.
And this stuff here
is beautiful.
Because it's a green color,
a soft green color.
And the French even have
a name for it.
They call it the green
fairy, la fee verte.
So this is what absinthe
looks like.
Beautiful.
Very nice.
And it's got the same kind
of licorice smell to it.
And so you make the louche by
one part absinthe and five
parts water.
So this, at no upcharge,
you get this glass.
It's a beautiful piece
of, you know, late
Belle Epoque glassware.
And the interesting thing is,
these people were absolutely
crazy, scientifically.
And so what they did is, the
markings on this glass are
such that if you put absinthe up
to this ring here, and then
you put water the rest of the
way, you get exactly the five
to one ratio for louche.
So you don't even
have to measure.
You just put like so.
OK.
Let's see.
I'm going to get this right!
It's science.
Here's our distilled water.
You see how it's milky?
So there's the louche.
And if you wanted to be a real
hipster, you had this special
Belle Epoque spoon.
And what you'd put on top of
this would be a sugar cube.
You know, this is
how it was done.
You have to know some culture.
You don't know.
You've led sheltered lives.
You pour it through
here, like this.
So now I'm going to
show you the art.
So David, may we cut to
the slides again?
So there's the louche.
All right.
So here's the poster.
Here's the man.
He's pouring the water through
the slotted spoon with the
thing, and there's a very
well-to-do lady, you can tell,
she's got a beautiful hat,
and she's well-dressed.
And he's inviting her to join
him for a glass of absinthe.
L'absinthe oxygenee.
That's the name of
the company.
The oxygenated absinthe.
C'est ma sante.
This is my health.
Van Gogh painted this.
This is Picasso.
The absinthe drinker.
There's the absinthe again.
This is Picasso after
many absinthes.
You can see the slotted spoon
and the sugar cube.
What else is there?
That's up to you.
All right.
When you saw Moulin Rouge, you
may not have known all of this
cultural history.
So now let's take a look at
what's going on here.
There's the absinthe, and I
think we've got a little--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I don't even know if I am a
true Bohemian revolutionary.
-Do you believe in beauty?
-Yes.
-Freedom?
-Yes, of course.
-Truth?
-Yes.
-Love?
Love.
Above all things, I
believe in love.
Love is like oxygen.
Love is a many-splendored
thing--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Love is like oxygen.
Chemistry is everywhere!
All right, so this is what
happens eventually.
This is the poster.
This is from Switzerland.
October 7, 1910.
Gentleman, This Is the Hour!
And there's the clergyman with
the Bible, and there's the
green fairy.
And she has a wand.
She's been stabbed, but she's
lying here with a wand.
The wand is an opalescent wand,
because this stuff is
opalescent.
Last thing I'll show you is
some really, really cool
chemistry that you
must remember.
When Toulouse-Lautrec drank--
let's go back, David,
to the thing.
So when Toulouse-Lautrec drank
absinthe, and he drank lots of
it, he didn't like
the milky color.
So he wanted to make the
milky color disappear.
So I'm in the two-phase
regime, and
I've got an oily phase.
And so how do I get rid
of the oily phase?
What he did is he added cognac
And why did he add cognac?
Not because he was a
hard-drinking alcoholic.
It's because if you've got a fat
phase here, and you've got
an aqueous phase here,
and if you add
alcohol, you've got CH3CH2OH.
This can bond to the water by
a hydrogen bond, and this
aliphatic tail can
stab the fat and
bring them into solution.
That's why you have
these recipes.
Do you ever wonder why the
recipe says, add brandy, or
add this, and then two steps
later, it says flame?
You say, geez, I just put
the brandy in, now
it's vaporizing away.
Isn't that kind of stupid?
No, it's not!
This is what you're doing.
You're cosolvating.
If you're ever making a cream
sauce or something, and all of
a sudden, everything
just curdles?
First you scream.
You go, ahhh!
Phase separation.
The second thing you do, is you
get some of this, and you
cosolvate it.
All right.
So let's see what Lautrec did.
Lautrec--
I might have to dilute
the volume here.
We've got quite a lot in here.
So just to make the point.
So here's the louche, ad now
we're going to add cognac.
He called this drink, Le
Tremblement de Terre.
The earthquake.
He had a walking stick a meter
long that was hollow, and it
always had this in it.
Look!
Look at that.
Isn't that something?
So now it's this beautiful
blonde, golden color.
It's clear.
So this is all phase separation
and so on.
At the end, it's all
about chemistry.
All right.
We'll see you on Wednesday
for our wrap-up.
Good.